(audience applauds)
- It's DRock's birthday.
(audience cheers)
Looks good for 40.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
Headed to a
meeting this morning,
with Steve Ross,
my business partner,
owner of the Dolphins,
real estate mogul.
All around great
dude, excited for it,
always enjoy our time together.
Actually trying
to do a better job,
he yelled at me the
other day, he's like,
why don't you take me up
on spending time together?
It's probably a good
idea to spend time with people
that have professionally
achieved the things
that you're
trying to accomplish,
especially by
building the biggest building
instead of tearing
other people's buildings down.
So he's a great man and
I'm excited for our meeting
right now, I'll try to
get a highlight with him.
("I Just Know" by Bugus)
All right Steve,
how was the meeting?
- The meeting was great, any
meeting with you is good.
- And what about
a piece of advice,
there's so many young
entrepreneurs who aspire
to be a 10th of
what you've accomplished.
What's your one or
two words of wisdom?
- Believe in yourself,
and be passionate
in what you're doing.
- And how are the
Dolpins gonna do this year?
- No predictions.
- And what about Michigan
in this tournament?
- Well, I still hope
they have the heart that
they showed and keep going.
- I need a prediction,
you're on the record.
- I'm not a prediction guy.
- Final four?
- People you know, when
you get to a certain point
and you make
predictions, you're quoted
all over the place,
I just hope for the best.
- Thanks.
I feel like we see
the world the same.
I have zero idea
how this crosses over
into what you've
got going on already,
but I strategically
decided, you know what,
I'm gonna change my course,
even though I've been going
down a path, I'm gonna get
this in front of (censored)
if she's interested,
great, then we'll flesh it out,
if not, then I'll just
move on my merry way.
But here is the punchline...
("Inhale" by JayTwo)
Speaks to respect.
Hi.
- Hi, I have a question.
You have Jewel's book right?
On the floor
down there somewhere?
- [Gary] Yeah, probably.
- Could you sign it,
can I have it?
Can you sign it?
- You want me to
sign Jewel's book?
- Yeah, then I
want to read it, yeah,
and I want to
remember that it came from you.
Like inscribe it.
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- Are you up to something
weird?
- No, no, I just love Jewel
and I love you.
- That's amazing.
- Miss you Gary.
- Miss you more.
- Oh, I'm so excited.
- This is how you
become a killer winner.
I had a man at a wine tasting,
I came up, he's pouring,
at the Marriott,
hot Australian wine,
he starts pouring, he looks up,
he goes, get the
fuck out of my table.
He goes, you're
the worst piece of shit
that has ever
happened to the wine business.
He goes, you're selling this
wine way too low in price.
Before I could explain that
the way Wine Library priced
was we would look
at the lowest prices
in the country and match them,
he blamed me, because what would
happen is if there was five
little stores in Michigan
or Orlando that had a price,
we would match that, but
nobody knew those stores.
And we were the big guy,
so the other 15 big guys
would have this at
$39.99 and I would be $34.99,
and I would get the
blame for setting that price
even though if you
went to WineSearcher.com,
there was a ton
of people at $34.99.
He shit on me, and I mean,
I've never felt that way.
You know like when you
get blood rushed to your head?
- [Man] Yeah.
- So that happened.
Three years later
I get an email from him,
I'd really love to
be on Wine Library TV.
(man laughing)
It'd be really important,
I'd love the chance
to be on Wine Library TV.
Three people that
knew about that story
in my world were in my
inbox, they were like, aah.
I replied, sure,
and had him on the show.
Then those three were
waiting for me to trick him,
get him in the
episode, never happened.
- [Man] Any acknowledgement
from this guy?
- No, he didn't say
anything and I didn't,
because when
you're the bigger man
you don't get to razz either.
Life is long, life is long.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Kenny] Nice to meet you.
- Gary.
- Kenny Cousins.
- Real pleasure Kenny,
one thing you should do
in this company, it's a
little bit slightly turned
on what you just asked,
but it's the absolute truth,
is you should get to
know every single person
in this company. With
every ounce of my soul,
I'm telling you right now,
every one of your lunches,
if you've got the time
and you're not on something,
should be in the cafeteria.
You should literally roll up
and be like, yo,
hey, it's everything.
People is the game, the skills
are commoditized, my man.
The skills are like taking
good notes, being organized,
being on time, being smart,
they're stunningly commoditized.
It's the relationships.
How'd you get here?
You played
lacrosse with somebody.
Relationships, right?
You shake somebody's hand,
you become friends with them.
Do you understand what
VaynerMedia is gonna be?
VaynerMedia is
going to be the company
that spits out the digital
ninjas of the future world.
Somebody in this room
right now is literally the CEO
of Nike, right now.
Somebody in this
office is the CEO of Nike,
17 years from now.
It would have been
really good if
you said what's up.
What the fuck?
- Perfect after day one
means nothing.
- and I mean,
I've got five losses,
it means something.
- We'll see, stay hot.
What's up dude?
- Yeah, so I think continuation.
So 1:09, I don't know
how the time went so fast
today, Jesus, right?
About to do a
company all hand on meeting,
which should be good,
90 minutes of Q&amp;A,
town hall, just a lot of
good client meetings brewing,
but really internal
right now, just super internal.
I like doing this
rant through the glass.
- What's up dude?
- 'Sup dude?
- You look all fashioned out.
- Hi.
- Hi Gary.
- Everybody is so religious
about doing what they do,
you just fuckin' make it,
the answer is yes, right?
The answer is yes
when you're at this point.
Like what do you do?
Yep.
(group laughter)
Let's go.
(whistling)
Let's go, let's do it.
Let's do this, take your salad.
Let's go, you
guys allowed to go?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Good.
Good afternoon,
VaynerMedia, how are you?
(audience cheers)
I'm really excited
about today's all hands on,
I'm really looking
forward to the Q&amp;A session.
I'm super excited
about where we're at,
I'm completely
blown away by PureWow
and their culture and
their company and the people
behind it, so excited
for when they move here
to Hudson Yards for you
guys to get to know them
on a personal level, just
a really good relationship
that's brewing, I'm really
excited about the acceleration
of some of the work. I don't
think I've been more happy
about the way
the company is moving
over the last 45 to 60 days.
I root for only the
attention of the end consumer.
It's unbelievable, even though
I wrote an ungodly check
into Snapchat years
ago, how little I would care
if they went out
of business tomorrow,
and Facebook, and anything else,
like, just want to
know where the attention is.
Good day.
Company wide chat, we'll
obviously have to edit that
carefully and
strategically, but we got a lot
of points across,
feeling pretty good.
(audience applause)
Love you, L.A.,
Chattanooga, love you guys.
- How was that, did
you hear real questions?
- I mean, yes and no,
I think it was actually
a pretty good start,
we didn't get the question
that everybody was scared of,
and we answered, but I think
we definitely set a
little bit of a foundation.
Amazing client meeting,
couldn't show that right?
Potential client meeting, beast,
might be a breakthrough
account in size and impact,
so, feeding the beast.
Trying to build an
incredible company.
Some of you saw this clip.
- You're an
influencer you could say,
but you're also a CEO,
you're an entrepreneur,
you're a businessman,
how do you balance between
your own personal brand
and then being responsible
to a company and
employees and all that?
- I run my company.
I'm the CEO of an 800 person,
$130 million a year
business and that takes up
all my time. The GaryVee
thing is my side hustle.
Which is what I actually do,
you just watched it.
It's the truth. This is
the side hustle, operating.
Really operating.
Alright, 60 Second Club,
make you an announcement
right now, I'm feeling it,
I'm gonna go hard next week.
Next week I am going to give
away some shadow sessions.
I've been giving
away a lot of t-shirts,
a lot of signed books,
but we're going super hard.
We're going super hard
next week, 60 Second Club.
Like and comment in the
first minute on my Instagram,
make sure you hit
up the notifications,
show them that screen
right now, what to do,
how to turn them
on so you get it,
and I'm gonna give away
three next week, committing,
Tyler, get it on the
calendar, three one-hour
shadow sessions in New York.
You just follow me,
while me and Babin or me
and DRock are filming,
you'll just be there,
a fly on the wall,
learn some real shit,
high five, spend five,
10 minutes together
yapping about your shit,
and you'll just fly on the
wall, we'll find the perfect
hour for you, you can
come and hang at Vayner
for four, five hours, but
you'll get one hour with me.
And yeah.
So better get
your fucking Instagram
notifications up,
boys and girls.
Been thinking a lot about
which is forced serendipity,
or serendipity,
when I hear that,
biggest piece of advice,
what should I do here?
It's say hello to people, right?
One thing that has
been good in the feedback
from people four,
five, six months in
is when they've taken that
tact, they've been so surprised
how warm somebody
is when they say hello,
that they're
willing to say hello back.
We just don't have
enough matches in the company.
I'm also spending a
lot of time watching,
in the same way that I
make decisions about social,
and where the world is
going, I do it by watching,
the majority of the reason we
don't have a lot of structure
in place is I have a very good
read on you by letting you
have a lot of room to do you.
Yo, who wants a pencil fight?
Who knows how to pencil fight?
- Holy shit.
You won, Boyd beat me. I broke
my own pencil, holy shit.
That's how you win this game.
You need to be the ones,
that's how at 50 and 80, the
people who have been here
five, six years,
that's what they did,
a lot of hands
just went up, right?
And I know some of
the hands that went up,
and they haven't said
hello randomly to anybody yet.
Let's go, let's go
De Simone get in here.
That's my jam, pencil fight.
See you, one shot baby, let's
go, no rebuttal, you're out.
- [Alex] What do
you mean no rebuttal?
- So you can't think
about it, you gotta do it.
You can't have it both ways.
You can't have us take care
of it and then complain about
the way it was taken care of.
And you can't, when I
completely let you have
the freedom to do it,
not do anything about it.
Then you're just
fucking complaining.
You guys are like
the minor leagues.
Minor leagues, let's go Benrubi.
- Who gets to go?
- You go first, I don't mind.
Pencil fighting,
I'm bringing it back,
get your pencils ready.
We're back, pencil
fighting, get ready.
Heading to Vancouver, see you.
One in the morning,
just got to Vancouver,
headed to the
hotel, hustle is real.
("I Just Know" by Bugus)